ronald whitlock i'm not sure if you  heard but there's been an incident  my son  cops killed him it's a bit more  complicated than that  it's crystal clear to me  i did not think i'd see your ass in work  today we come from tougher part than  that why'd you like ex-military yourself  yeah you're a fugitive i killed two cops  i got a bone to pick  for my son  [Music]  if things don't go to my satisfaction  [Music]  i'll flood this whole place  we're all gonna drown  [Music]  sorry dude  got a town to save  there's a rogue hostage  with some sort of military background  find him  [Music]  i gotta figure out a way to stop this  food  they got guns  you got a goddamn ghost  i got bear guns  open another gate  they're gonna flood the entire county  that is beautiful  [Music]  this is my legacy  you're crazy man you should try a little  bit of  crazy  you